SPEAKER 1: May you serve the
Institute with all the skill,
wisdom, dedication--
SPEAKER 2: He is tremendously
prepared for this job.
He knows MIT inside and out.
He is a community builder.
SPEAKER 3: He empowers and
energizes and gets so much of
the community trying
new things.
SPEAKER 4: I think it's awesome
that he was already
championing MITx when
he was the provost.
And so, I think as we go forward
Edx will get a lot of
attention and I'm really
excited about that.
DR. L. RAFAEL REIF: The MIT
I know loves challenges.
The MIT I know solves the
unsolvable, shapes the future,
and serves our nation
and the world.
The MIT I know and love does
not stand on the sidelines.
SPEAKER 5: One community--
SPEAKER 6: --together--
SPEAKER 7: --in service.
SPEAKER 8: [INAUDIBLE] back
into a user interface.
This is actually
our prototype.
SPEAKER 3: A big part of
this week's events
are these three symposia.
And I think they're a critical
part because they do showcase
elements of MIT, but they
also have begun
dialogue as we look forward.
SPEAKER 9: I'll spend some time
talking about how online
learning is borrowing from
gaming technologies.
SPEAKER 10: There's this giant
quilt that is MIT.
And there are so many different
beautiful patches there that
are being built, even as we
speak, and some have been
around for a long time.
SPEAKER 11: MIT has, and still
does, shape amazing
individuals that see the
entire world as their
playground.
SPEAKER 1: Ladies and gentlemen,
the 17th President
of the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology,
Dr. L. Rafael Reif.
SPEAKER 12: Rafael Reif is well
known to us at Harvard
for his insight and
his judgment.
He is a generous and genuine
convener who listens as much
as he speaks.
SPEAKER 13: We like the rhythm
of his name, Rafael Reif.
Thus, you are about to hear
a rumba for Rafael Reif.
DR. L. RAFAEL REIF: Society
continues to need what the
residential
research university does
better than any other
institution--
incubate brilliant, young talent
and create the new
knowledge and innovation
that fuel our society.
I will lead MIT to continue to
make significant contributions
in the area of race and
diversity, equity, and inclusion.
We have many compelling
suggestions
for practical change.
These include better ways to
search for and mentor new
talent and to improve the
orientation process for new
members of our community.
SPEAKER 14: We're able to reach
out to a lot of people,
have a run on campus.
We're promoting a lot of ideals
here, obviously, like
health and fitness, Habitat
for Humanity, general
community wellness, and, like,
community joining together,
and, of course, like celebrate
our new president.
SPEAKER 15: Around the Dome
Campus Quest is a campus-wide
scavenger hunt.
SPEAKER 16: All the groups just
go through and see how
many of the challenges
they can complete.
SPEAKER 15: Things like the LED
Light-Up Challenge, the
Origami Challenge, and then
we had a Bungee Run.
SPEAKER 16: It's a really great
reminder that we have
such a strong community here and
that the culture is really
important to everyone.
SPEAKER 12: And now, despite
silently suffering torment and
humiliation these many years
as the victim of MIT's
creative hackers, John Harvard
has dressed himself up for
today's occasion.
President Reif, on behalf of
the Red Brick School up the
street, I present a symbol of
our lasting friendship.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 17: We had an
inauguration reception
luncheon for our 17th
President, Dr.
Rafael Reif, today.
DR. L. RAFAEL REIF: Thank you.
Good meeting you.
Thank you very much.
SPEAKER 17: And it was for all
of the support staff here.
He wanted to meet all of
the support staff.
DR. L. RAFAEL REIF: It was
very nice meeting you.
SPEAKER 18: It's such a pleasure
to be recognized and
to see President.
It was very nice that he could
make it and took his time and
came and said thank you to us.
That was very special.
DR. L. RAFAEL REIF:
We are all in this
great enterprise together.
We have a great deal
to accomplish, and
the world is waiting.
So let's get started.
[APPLAUSE]